I've come face-to-face with death more
times than I can count
as a Salem PD detective it's my job to
catch killers but in all my years in the
force
I never saw this case
O'Conner is a homicide detective with a
criminal past guilty on two counts of
grand theft auto on the indictment of
Birds grand larceny and assault with a
deadly weapon but just when he'd started
turning things around he lost everything
including his life
but none of us can move on to the next
world until we finish what we need to in
this world you're here to resolve
something you don't resolve it you don't
leave in Salem a town with a dark
history there's a killer on the loose
he's killed before and then he'll kill
again police to refer to the murderer as
a bail killer Ronin couldn't stop him in
life
in death he's got a second chance hidden
somewhere as a trail that leads to his
killer he just has to find it Ronin has
lost the ability to question witnesses
interrogate suspects and interact with
the physical world but he's gained
abilities that are even more valuable
your strengths in life are stronger in
death they become powers here
Ronan's death gives him the ability to
pass through walls a freedom that
quickens his search for the killer but
not everything is open to Ronin dusk
objects that goes of tragic events which
lead powerful everlasting imprints
cannot be passed through
hidden in this purgatorial world are
hundreds of clues about Salem its
history and its people some of the
deceased remain trapped as well and each
has a story to tell I can't remember
what happened to me
combining everything he finds here is
the only way Ronan
copy the bull mysteries of Salem but not
all spirits in the dusk world can help
some will stand in his way will devour
any soul they can
costs but if you can't then on lemonade
not all among the living are blind to
the duska Ronin you can see me you're a
medium gaining the trust of a partner
from the living world would be an
invaluable asset for Ronan my mother is
been missing for a few days
we know the Bell killer had something to
do with her disappearance but he must
use this advantage to find his killer
quickly as time is running out
Ronin will need to use the skills he
honed in life when the abilities he
gained in death to put an end to the
killing he can possess any living being
and hear their inner private thoughts
out of one guy do this see through their
eyes to reveal vital clues and influence
their actions progressing deeper into
his journey Ronin will acquire new and
more powerful abilities abilities that
will help him traverse and survive the
dusk world to bring him closer to the
truth about his murder why him
why that night
was he just in the wrong place at the
wrong time
[Music]
or was there something more at work
there are clues that have been left in a
bloody wake of the BAL killer like any
good detective Ronin must gather
evidence and establish what is relevant
to aid him he can utilize a new ability
he gained in death the power to see and
hear past events by piecing his clues
together he can reveal hidden truths
with the answers Ronin finds only lead
to more questions as the killer's trail
spreads a bizarre mystery is beginning
to unfold something Sinister's have
worked
but how many more will die before
running can stop it
you
[Music]